je pense que la race etc tommy comme en
général la contraception est un une
affaire de couple
dans les années soixante dix en france
cet homme faisait partie des rares à
défendre la vasectomie sur un plateau de
télévision et je ne vois pas pourquoi ma
femme je serais obligé à elles seules
d'assumer ses responsabilités une parole
forte alors que la contraception est
principalement une affaire de femmes la
vasectomie est pourtant une méthode
ancienne qui consiste à sectionner les
canaux qui transportent les
spermatozoïdes
elle est irréversible et dans les années
70 elle était loin de faire l'unanimité
d'ailleurs pour ce médecin sa
généralisation n'était pas pour demain
je crois que c'est dû à des préjugés
tout à fait votre avis c'est à dire que
tout ce qui touche aux organes génitaux
de l'homme c'est sacré à la femme que
touchait groupe la vasectomie associé à
halle en puissance une fausse idée qui
résistent dans la tête des français
ce préjugé a aussi été renforcée par le
vide juridique qui a longtemps entouré
la stérilisation en france 1977 cet
urologue expliquer cette ambiguïté alors
la stérilisation n'est ni légale ni
légale en ce sens qu'il n'existe dans le
code civil ou dans le code pénal
aucune loi interdisant la stérilisation
malgré ce flou juridique dans les années
80 des médecins continuer d'encourager
cette alternative exemple dans cet
hôpital nantais en 1983 près de 300 amis
avaient subi une vasectomie
et pour convaincre les autres ce
spécialiste se voulait rassurant il
s'agit donc plus d'intervention qui est
pratiquée sous anesthésie locale
c'est une intervention qui demande
murat trois quarts d'heure qui est très
simple et qui permet aux hommes de
reprendre dans les heures qui suivent
notre activité en france le cadre
juridique de la vasectomie n'est défini
qu'en 2001 année de sa légalisation
officiel une étape législative qui ne
suffira pas à convaincre les plus
réfractaires exemple en 2010 de mutiler
se couper ses canaux pour faire plaisir
à madame ou je ne sais quoi c'est
excusez moi mais on est dans
l'aberration total faire ça ça existe
déjà aujourd'hui encore les vasectomies
sont rares en france
d'après les données de l'assurance
maladie seul 4836 homme avait recouru à
une stérilisation en 2017
[Musique]